uh how dope is it for you to see your
boy Millie's just thriving out here man
I love it bro and I knew it the whole
time project together you know what's
crazy big shout out to set free you know
I'm saying that that really bridged that
connected that you know what I'm saying
like back back before this [__] really
was cracking for me like we met in the
Bronx
at the original compound that set free
had you know I'm saying and Millie's
from day one
um
he hungry yeah you know what I mean I
respect hungry like like people that's
really embedded in the culture it ain't
about the jewelry like I love to see
somebody glow up but that ain't it ain't
really about that right you know as time
go on you make more money you advance
you're gonna you're gonna do you're
gonna look a little different right but
he still stick to the script of what we
got into this [__] for you know what I'm
saying like he the reason I went to
Columbia
like I love I love melies